We do a real live action Toy Story where we
take a 65-year-old Tom Hanks and a 68-year-old
Tim Allen.
We put them in a cowboy outfit and a little
spaceman suit, and we have them run away from
a 65-foot-tall eight-year-old.
Today we're going to talk animated shows and
movies that deserve a live action version.
We've got this article up on looper.com that
has a lot of interesting choices that, no
disrespect to the writer, I don't love because
a lot of them involve animals.
And I feel like The Lion King remake makes
me feel like some of them would be not great,
but what do I know?
Because they wouldn't necessarily be live
action if they're all just computer generated.
That's not really live action, but here we
are.
I'm just going to-
What were some of the examples there, if you
don't mind me asking?
I think one that could work best out of some
of these is American Tail with Fievel, a little
mouse immigrant comes to America.
You can film it on city streets.
You can make practical sets if you wanted
to, I don't know, do it with puppets.
I have no idea.
But if you did CG, I would wonder about how
well that would work.
Yeah.
We don't want to get too far into-
Can we just do it Wishbone style?
... the uncanny valley situation.
Wishbone style would be interesting.
Is it live action or is it CG, right?
Right.
Land Before Time is on here.
Disney has a version of that called Dinosaur.
They also did a Pixar, The Good Dinosaur,
not the same story, but same idea.
Secret of NIMH, is that live action?
All Dogs Go to Heaven is one that could work.
That's a pretty good example here, although-
That is a tough sell.
Really?
It's a tough sell.
I'm saying as far as working in live action.
I'm not saying-
what you're pitching right now is a movie
where we watch two dogs die in real life this
time.
Okay, cool.
I'm going to go ahead and pass.
That's the first act.
But we can get Charlie Sheen involved again.
He was in the sequel, right?
It was, what's his name?
What was the sequel?
All Dogs Go to Hell featuring-
All Dogs Go to Heaven 2.
Who was in the first one?
It was-
I don't know.
I don't know, but I'm very thrown by the beginning
of this entire thing.
Burt Reynolds was the star of All Dogs Go
to Heaven 1.
Now he is in heaven.
Charlie Sheen was, I believe-
You don't know that.
... the voice of Charlie in All Dogs Go to
Heaven 2, where they came up with some other
kid.
Dom DeLuise was in it.
Right.
Doesn't-
None of this matters.
Doesn't the first one actually end with them
sending a dog to hell?
I only watched it one time when I was a kid.
Don Bluth is a weird dude.
No, the dog never goes to hell.
He goes to heaven as well.
Doesn't the bad guy dog at the end go to hell?
No.
No, he goes to heaven?
He goes to heaven goes.
He goes to doggie heaven.
He's really upset about it because he doesn't
want to be dead.
And he hates heaven because it's so nice.
Oh, same.
But all dogs go to heaven.
It is there in the title.
I retract my earlier statement.
No, we got to explore this universe.
There's some deeply fascinating theology happening.
There's some stuff here, yeah.
We've got Watership Down on here as well,
which is one I don't think I can get behind
for various reasons.
We'll move right past it.
FernGully could work.
They did that.
It was Avatar.
Next.
Okay, moving on.
Moving on.
I'm scrolling, I'm scrolling.
I'm looking for any that don't star animals.
Here we go.
This is one of the ones that I wanted to talk
about.
If we decided to cut everything we just talked
about, I would say an animated movie or show
that I think could get a live action reboot
that would be really great would be Gargoyles.
Are either of you familiar with Gargoyles.
Nope.
Love Gargoyles.
Can you tell me about it?
Gargoyles is the story of these gargoyles,
who-
That's about as succinct as it gets.
That was really well done.
All right.
I understand everything now.
You pretty much do.
We can all go home.
Like vampires, they can't operate during the
day.
When the sun goes down-
Well, right.
They break out of their-
I mean, people are walking around.
... stone forms and become monstrous superheroes.
Basically-
The stones are like shells.
They just bust out, and they're like...
Pretty much.
Exactly.
It's got a great theme song, which goes like:
(singing)
I'm
so excited to plug the opening titles of Gargoyles
in.
What?
Huh?
It's going to be great footage to just layer
together, you doing that and then the opening
sequence from gargoyles.
I feel like I did a really good job.
I want everyone to at home to know that we're
all wearing headphones for this show.
You're welcome.
That hurt.
Yeah.
I made sure to turn my sound settings way
up because I was having trouble with the microphone.
So it's as loud as it gets.
The story of Gargoyles-
Can't hear anything.
... is that back in medieval times, middle
ages, whatever humans and gargoyles coexisted.
Gargoyles protected the kingdom, and because
of some kind of curse, they were basically
cursed to sleep forever in their stone forms.
Sure.
And then eventually-
Happens to the best of us.
The castle is moved from medieval Europe to
New York in modern day by a bad businessman
guy named Xanatos.
Jonathan Frakes.
Voiced by Commander Riker, Jonathan Frakes.
Yes, another Star Trek reference.
Or Thomas Riker, come on.
Or Thomas Riker, his evil transporter clone,
not evil, but you know.
But anyway, so then the curses lifted, and
they become modern day protectors of New York.
And it's great.
It's this great cartoon.
It's on Disney+.
If you haven't checked it out, you should.
It's a good show.
Keith David did the voice of Goliath, the
main guy, and the voice is perfect.
Keith David's an amazing actor, an amazing
voice actor.
I would love to see a live action Gargoyles.
I think it's probably one of my favorite items
on this list as an idea because Disney owns
the IP.
They're always looking for new stuff to do
with their intellectual property.
It's something that's not Marvel.
It's not Disney.
It's not Star Wars, I mean.
It's fully Disney owned, and they could just
do it whenever they're ready.
And it would have an already rabid fan base
that would be totally into it.
I would love to see it.
I think our Gargoyles would be awesome.
I think that would be cool.
It would be mostly CG though, right?
No, that's the thing.
It takes place in modern day New York, so
you'd have TMNT style, like the Michael Bay
produced-
Right.
Right, right, right.
You've got CGI characters.
Right.
But then humans alongside them.
Got it.
Exactly.
That would be cool.
Alvin and the Chipmunks style, Squeakquel
style.
Sonic the Hedgehog style.
Sonic the Hedgehog style or-
Cats style, we take people's faces and we
plug them into barely-
Let's do it Cats style.
Yeah.
We'll cut that part.
Digital fur technology.
Digital fur.
We are living in the golden age, people.
Let's take advantage.
The golden age of cinema.
Yeah.
The only other one on here that I really responded
to is Voltron, which is-
Fascinating.
... right here.
There he is.
See, there's Voltron right there.
I mean, basically Voltron is Power Rangers.
That's basically what it is, but it's not
quite as heavy on the goofy Kung Fu action,
the martial arts action that happens in a
lot of the Power Ranger shows.
It was animated, but instead of Zords, they're
lions.
They all get into their lions, the lions form
a giant robot, the robot fights aliens.
I could just-
Just like in nature.
That's in The Lion King.
Everyone knows.
That's how that movie ended.
I think I saw a documentary about that on
Animal Planet.
Yeah.
That's when Simba was finally ready to ascend,
he formed up with four other lions and fought
scar who was at that point a giant Robeast.
Yeah.
But I would love to see everyone a live action-
Everyone knows that story.
It's a tale as old as time.
Oh, wrong movie.
(singing)
And Beyonce sang.
It was good.
Lions joined together!
This is getting rougher.
I'll stop.
It's a musical episode.
That's perfect.
It's a very special episode of Blossom here
at the Looper talk show.
Is this better or worse than the musical episode
of Grey's Anatomy?
Nothing's better than that.
Oh, much worse.
Those are my big picks.
Voltron and Gargoyles are my two faves from
my childhood.
And even revisiting, the Netflix had a Voltron
reboot that was animated and excellent, really
good stuff.
Didn't quite get to the finish line unscathed.
The end of the series wasn't as good as the
rest of it, would make you hope that the finale
was, but overall I'd still really recommend
it to anyone who likes-
Perfect.
... action, sci-fi, comedy, giant robots,
cool stuff.
Nice.
The stuff everybody likes.
Yeah.
The stuff everyone likes forever.
Nina.
Yeah.
Your response to my question that is this
topic.
Here is my answer.
That was the worst-
Animated movies and shows-
That was like Carson.
That was so-
... that deserve a live-
the worst Yoda jeopardy phrasing I've ever
heard.
Well, this was an easy answer.
I believe it is in the article on looper.com,
but I probably would've picked it anyway because
it's one of my favorite shows ever.
And if we're singing theme songs, I feel like
you probably both know it's (singing) is the
theme song to this.
It's Daria.
I love Daria very much.
Beautiful.
I first started watching it on The N, a channel
that kept me as an unpopular high schooler
company between its airings of Degrassi: The
Next Generation and Daria.
Yeah.
But Daria, I'm sure you're both familiar with
Daria.
It's about a misanthropic teenager, who's
way smarter than everybody else.
And she hangs out with her cool artist best
friend Jane Lane, and they watch Sick, Sad
World.
And her parents are weird and funny, and her
sister's cute and popular, and hijinks
ensue.
But it is a very, very insightful, funny show
about what it's like to be different in high
school and what it's like to kind of be wise
beyond your years and her kind of struggling
with that she wants to be an outsider, but
sometimes she does want to just be a little
more kind of mainstream and fit in.
It's a great show.
It's super funny.
Her dad is the most neurotic character in
television history.
Oh, the parents are so good.
The parents are so good.
She also has that one teacher that's always,
I don't remember his name, but one of his
eyeballs is always in danger of leaving his
head-
Yeah, he's always-
Because he's really mad all the time.
And then she also has that wishy-washy dope
of a teacher, who's always like, guys, why
can't we just hold hands and be friends?
And the sister.
Quinn, who is a lot smarter than her dopey
friends in the fashion club.
Fashion club.
The fashion club.
Her friend Sandi with the weird monotone voice.
And then Tiffany talks like this.
Yeah.
The cheerleader Brittany and a really dumb
boyfriend Kevin.
Great cast.
Great everything.
It's a great show.
Yeah.
There were rumors about this, and they just
never happened.
I don't know why.
But Aubrey Plaza is right there.
She's right-
Just go get her.
... there.
And have her play Daria.
She is right there.
I can't imagine anyone else doing that.
She still looks like she could.
Even if she doesn't look 17, I'd be like,
I don't care, whatever.
Don't Dear Evan Hansen her.
Just let her do it.
I was just going to say, you might have a
Dear Evan Hansen situation.
Nah, because everybody would just be like,
no, this is correct.
This makes complete sense.
Everybody would be cool about it.
Also, we wouldn't-
The heart wants what it wants.
Nobody would put makeup on her to make her
look like Steve Buscemi in 30 Rock going how
do you do, fellow kids?
She won't look like an undercover cop.
I mean, I feel like Meredith Hagner, who was
in Palm Springs and Search Party would be
really funny as Brittany.
Oh my God.
Yes.
She would crush it.
Great cast there.
I think it would be really fun to fan cast
this.
Maybe Laurie Metcalf could be her high-strung
lawyer mom.
I don't know who I want to be her neurotic
dad yet.
We're all cool with this, right?
This is just a thing that should have happened
a long time ago.
A Daria live action movie makes sense.
There's no fantastical animals.
You don't have to have any CGI.
It could just be a funny, smart show.
Also, they could make more Sick, Sad World
hypotheticals, and I would really, really
love that.
It would be great.
Because I want to watch that show for real.
I want to watch Daria live on screen.
Someone call Aubrey.
Get her agent on the phone.
Let's go.
You know that-
Let's get moving.
... they'll probably reboot it for Netflix
in a few years, and it's just going to be
the worst.
It'll just be the worst.
Yeah, it could be, but I also will say this
is not a reboot.
I mean, actually, it's a reboot of movies
and a book series, but Netflix redid Baby-Sitters
Club, and it's really good.
Okay.
So there you go.
And I'm not alone in this, critics actually
like it, but it's an endearing, nice, well-written
show with Alicia Silverstone hanging out as
a parent.
Oh, that's awesome.
Yeah.
And so, it's like-
All right, cool.
Well then, Netflix, get on it.
If they could pull off Baby-Sitters Club,
maybe they could do Daria.
Let's see what they've got.
Yeah.
Alicia Silverstone plays a parent in it?
We're all old.
Is she being a regular parent or an Alicia
Silverstone parent?
Is she baby birding anyone?
No.
If that were the case, I would not be singing
this show's praises.
And Shawn from The Good Place is a dad, but
not a demon this time.
Oh, cool.
Luckily.
Yeah.
All right.
Anyway, Daria. That's my pick.
Tom, what do you got?
Marc Evan Jackson? I think that's his name.
Thomas. Tom. Old Tommer.
His name is Marc Evan Jackson.
How are you?
What do you got? What do you got for us?
I hate this because-
Take us home, Tom.
I don't like to pick the low-hanging fruit,
Brian.
You know that about me.
But I think there's one obvious choice.
It's pretty good. It's a classic.
The best part about it is you could get all
the people who played the characters originally
to come back in and play them in live action.
I think we all know what I'm talking about,
1995, it's Toy Story.
We do a real live action Toy Story, where
we take a 65-year-old Tom Hanks and a 68-year-old
Tim Allen.
We put them in a cowboy outfit and a little
spaceman suit, and we have them run away from
a 65-foot-tall eight-year-old.
Someone call Disney.
We got somebody-
Disney right now.
... painted green as a live action army man.
He gets tied to a giant firework and exploded
in front of everybody.
Ooh, ooh.
The worst.
Where are we getting a real dinosaur?
I've ever pictured.
Sid's room.
Can we get some dinosaur bones and do some
science magic and make a dinosaur and make
him be in the movie?
I love that idea.
The worst thing I've ever envisioned.
I think that's terrific.
How do we make a human piggy bank?
A human piggy bank sounds like a joke from
a Stefon sketch on SNL.
Do you want to be-
A human piggy bank?
Wow.
What's a human piggy bank?
Guys, I came up with this idea-
... 45 minutes ago, and I've been having a
hard time thinking about anything else ever
since.
It's that thing where you keep coins in your
shirt.
And then you let them fall into the floor,
and you're like, I'm a piggy bank.
That's what it is.
The thing where a man in the front of the
club opens his mouth, and you have to feed
him quarters to get in.
There you go.
I was going to say, Nina, thank you for keeping
it PG about where you're putting the coins.
If SNL can keep Stefon PG, then we all can
do it.
And then you come back later and shake them
out.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like, and subscribe.